m
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il va se passer aujourd'hui
eh bien je me suis dit on à une djette
on a une djette et on sait qu'elle sait
mettre de la musique mais ce qu'elle
sait donc c'est dans un instant on fera
un ans avec kenny
après
sur la tête de ma mère la régie bechiri
elle est la nature
on dirait que je fais un duplex en
direction mexique les gars attention
première danse sur une salsa kelly et
son partenaire benjamin castaldi au
[Musique]
label il va la paire cris mais annonce
ainsi à tomber je mets un échantillon 1
sur 10 attention sur une mc amène à
kelly et sa partenaire valérie bel et
bien sûr kelly et son partenaire maxime
délit
[Musique]
c'est parti c'est moi c'est bon jeu mais
je mets 4 sur des spas sitôt kelly et
son partenaire damien caby belle ragga
ska ragga rossi oh la la
[Musique]
c'est beau stade ouvrage du spaceshiptwo
je retrouve alors jean-michel vert sur
nes pas site web professionnel qui a été
pour toi ton meilleur partenaire de
danse à valérie bouley valérie on enlève
valérie c'est maxime c'est maxime toinon
nul nantua nul maxime mais kelly j'ai
l'honneur de vous annoncer que vous
partez tous les deux pour un stage de
danse non le limousin payé par la
production adonnons vous partez une
semaine tous les deux ans suffira pas
voilà il y aura dans ce bien sûr et bien
sûr il ya plein far n'ya pas star
heureux heureux et épanoui et balazs la
mer contente
ah oui ça a l'air
[Musique]